scram hey everyone welcome back to
resident knievel yeah it's my job
nice to see you all how are you doing so
we had our hunters episode last week and
as you noticed I came unprepared I
didn't cosplay so you do [ __ ] no that's
not true mama Mary did everything I mean
I made a cool death thing where I
freaked out like okay for three minutes
so I'm on my road to redemption starting
with so we have some great fan artists
that have been doing some stuff so I
thought so I didn't know if our friend
Ava Cassandra through Instagram or
YouTube was constantly watching the show
and so I was like oh well I'm not sure
if he was gonna do anything for 100th
episode I think even mentioned that
she's going to anyway we love amen so I
was going to bring out some stuff so I
commissioned some stuff personally just
because I wanted to see yeah okay so she
made a few I'm gonna here's one joke so
you got obviously marry with Harry I
forgot about that allow me with my box
water yeah they're pooping you know
there's flies around the poop it's good
of course you're not your usual grade
vodka with her mega hat on that's really
good news for headphone users Mikey
gamespot resonable v co-op not sure if
that's in reference to us not being
friends but yeah Ace of Spades there's
there's a lot on here and we really like
it
golden egg from the golden egg and the
fact that you have boxed water and I
have beer it's also funny I'm here I'm
gonna go back to our camera for a second
because I'm pulling up another one
there's a few that was awesome but
you're amazing she also was kind enough
to do like a landscape version probably
for a while make this like my Twitter
a header or something it's the same
thing apologies we're covering up part
of it with our pips but it's the same
thing just landscape you'd see us and
then she also I don't know that I have
to show this but she did break a both
out as pngs as well oh I look so good my
little beer yeah I love each other maybe
it's bucho no it's not thick enough I've
never drank a bucho in my life yeah true
I'm the Booch you've used it in
resonable seven though yes and then
alright one more time the PSD that's
pretty funny I didn't mean the PS here's
me looking trim that profile no I don't
know I think she was generous generous
facial structure yeah I'm not that I'm
not still gonna say what gave you some
curves oh yeah gave me some cake there's
that urinal okay cool
now we'll get back into the second Oh
switch the HDMI that was awesome
baby you're amazing I think these really
do mean a lot to us and we do this
specifically because we enjoy it we
typically do it after work or like when
we have free time like this isn't like a
traditional thing and so it's really
it's just yeah it's really rewarding to
see people like it as much as we do mhm
we can quit any time we want
woah because we're addicted thanks so
much Ava and then um our friend Jaime
circus has also been practicing drawing
more yeah it was very skilled Jaime is
getting there he's uh he's been working
a lot on welcome only level man yeah
because that's the thing I suck I tried
to draw on my Instagram sometimes but
it's not very good
yeah friend Josh Shaw former GameSpot
draws and he draws like sexy women
sometimes he can but he's been doing it
for like two years and holy
he's good now like it Drago naked you
can see sometimes you can see their
boobs what's our what's the what's the
address not kidding it's Josh Contra I
love it okay sweet let's get into it so
last time we got the microfilm so we're
in the classroom again oh yeah I hope I
hope our audio is okay I haven't really
moving attention it's good
hopefully the faint sounds of footsteps
those of survivors what time is it six
o'clock so oh so also in addition to
reaching out to a very talented viewer
Ava for some 100th episode celebration I
know I last week I said that our the
montage Mary made would be on YouTube
separately I we had a very crazy week I
literally just had to top and tail it
with our GameSpot graphics but I think
it's going up on Facebook one of these
days like it's Thursday right now we're
recording this showing up on our
Facebook and then I talked to our
YouTube person Ryan and I'm gonna just
put like intro outro on it and I'll put
that up simultaneously this week at
least that's the plan I know I've made
promises before that I don't because
that is kind of out of my hands he our
YouTube channel I don't like yours word
is worth so little I know so that's I'll
try to cosplay as a certain character
from Resident Evil I don't have much
like I'm not great it I realized that
cosplay is like a fuckload of effort it
is I put on a tube top and I was like
exhausted where's Billy
he's over here I think I'm gonna do
Billy I already have the sleeve down I
just need to wear a tank top tucked into
jeans and maybe slick my hair back I was
gonna I was gonna split some of these
bullies because I don't want him not
having any like me so far in this season
of Knievel I've been more focused on
like comments at the beginning as you
mentioned then like guiding you so let
me pull
and then you need to drop you need to
drop these oh one thing this is the
sounds so negative cuz I loved your
montage the one thing that I really
wanted to is you you were bound by time
obviously and you guys there was so many
moments I wish I really had scares but
when I saw you included the Marguerite
fight I thought you were gonna show when
you shot that fly with the grenade
launcher
oh that was funny I remember when I did
that I I shot I did the part where I see
her for the first time like her whole
body and how [ __ ] gross she is oh
she's gross yeah sorry I'm pulling up
the previous episodes for that's not it
for comments yeah because actually don't
remember where to go so you did the
puzzle with these and you I thought you
got something or no no no member all the
Knight's Cross sword doors open right
but we don't know where they are we do I
remember there's one in this room
there's one in the front there's three
of them I know we're like two of them
are oh I'll if we get stuck on look at
the last one okay actually if you're
just joining the show let me if you
haven't been with us since past seasons
I do sometimes refer to walkthroughs
just to keep the show going she's on
coffee all what's your health situation
great I think I kind of like burned
through it last episode because I kind
of asked
where is the item that so the door at
the top left of the room that's a night
door so I have a green herb II here
where the [ __ ] is that I don't see it
oh that's cool I can change the category
that's weird I don't know why you'd want
to do that anyway what were you saying
this one yeah oh that's really close
would you like to go yeah might as well
cross it off so I know where one else is
on the bottom floor and from the main
it's the door we try it it's like the
front door I don't know what it where
it's gonna lead but I wonder if you need
that confuse its here to the left
why you stay here no it's way come with
me you idiot where is he there he is Oh
should I be him I'm supposed to be him
yeah probably on my way oh god I hope
there's not zombies in here all right
got my wait are you
back up [ __ ] I hear them I hear him I
hear him I hear him I don't have any
mall tops what if there's a I mean you
could keep going a little bit and then
run back if there is but I mean what's
what's your inventory your inventory
it's fine
god I hope there's [ __ ] bullets in
here because I am like on E ok so I have
two doors here I have a big one and I
have a little one little one first okay
it goes into like a dead end listen no
need to explain
I trust you really know ya gotta be some
stuff in here handgun rounds I loved a
little that he still has his handcuffs
on I'd like it too it's really also
mothers sorry start restart they were so
quiet yeah
sneaky sneaky I just wanted to I want to
like process this because I had like no
[ __ ] ammo and she doesn't have a lot
of ammo either you got 20 rounds with
her that's not a lot there was like at
least and then I was thinking about
giving these to him cuz like he's he's
got eight bullets yes but like what she
actually doesn't have any but that's her
only weapon he's got shotgun on the
bright side you're getting to the point
where you're like you're going deeper
into the training facility the mansion
whatever it is training facility
you're gonna use more general
rule-of-thumb you're gonna be you're
gonna be backtracking more so you're not
gonna be finding as many new people just
by the fact that you're running into
zombies I think you're fine I hear your
concern I mean it's a legit concern I
keep I keep leaving the menu yeah I know
you do it so much you notice that the
room is back to its orange color from I
do it so much she's been drinking all
day I love drinking okay yeah no yes
okay I did it okay I'm ready
all right I feel good let's do it
there's two it looks like okay also
there were blue herbs so I wonder what's
coming up
we each have 15 bullets that's it
that'll be more than enough get them in
your fielding not in this town doctor
dr. see you now blue an oxygen tank of
some sort oh you're in like an infirmary
that's good
[ __ ] beer coconut wait hey here's a
question grossest fruit durian based on
smell really oh yeah those are the
things those are really helpful in
breath of the wild
yes but they smell like dead people
that's hot
have you ever smelled one no I don't
oh wow they're gross like they're huge
they look like they look like they look
like my balls dragon eggs should I take
these now probably hey no okay I'll need
a container to carry chemical maybe like
and now you're talking about tastes is
that what you're saying I was just
making fun of how much I don't like
coconut but you were eating it I know
that's what's puzzling I feel like all
we're learning is how hypocritical you
are yes I had a critical that's
contradictory we're searching the
facilities and it looks a lot like the
chemicals survived we just started and
we don't there's still a lot we don't
know but they can be mixed the chemicals
are all over the place because a bunch
of idiots will have to develop a system
currently it's like whatever alright red
and blue is sulfuric acid green and red
is the stripping agent gotcha
red and blue sulphuric acid green red
stripping agent yeah try redstone I mean
use your brain green and red red and
blue sulfuric my friend red was blue
what I don't know so honestly they both
have red so blue is still furyk acid
okay and green is just stripping Chris
strippers
when I have a kid now we know we'll
never forget worst Christmas ever
like best is really weird taking my
clothes off though there really wasn't a
lot in here should I take these plants
now herbs as well at least you don't
have to take them maybe take one and
then I can take them and then I put them
somewhere else
I just interact with at least like do
this now press no so it'll show up on
your map at least okay at least as far
as our commenters have hinted at okay so
that was it for that and now we have to
go into the double the doobly doors and
hope God's sakes that there's
not a zombies I don't have enough ammo
sorry you know a parabola means it's two
separate words it's Italian for prepare
for war but I don't know that you really
yeah please no don't don't don't don't
don't
please don't I remember specifically
that if you do this wrong poison yes
comes into the room I'm not messing with
you no I'm saying I'm not kidding okay
oh you were so close to pushing the
wrong died grenades and something yeah
you can't I'm full
yeah at least you interacted with it the
grenade you probably don't need yet no I
don't have a grenade launcher all right
what's in the main lobby um is there
something else I'm missing in this room
because I don't know what to do with
these pieces
it's a chessboard
what's that checkmate um is that the
king yeah um well oh wait no I see no
matter where he moves no matter where
black moves it's gonna be it's checkmate
because the black keep the black black
lost no matter where they move both
rooks can get them yes but was that what
it wants from me too does it want you to
move produce a checkmate they probably
want no no it's already checkmate just
or no yes but I think it also because
it's already a checkmate for black but
on the board the king was south of that
rook by one square to the right cuz
right now you blacks not checkmate it's
fine right now it's not even checked by
moving the King it would be checkmate if
I'm sorry
what yeah by moving the King 1 south
it'll be check this King yeah cuz if I
move him south can't this guy get him no
cuz black is going this way toward the
camera
so is that what I'm doing I think you
just want to put it I think we're ever
thinking I think you just want to put it
where it was on the board you want to
match up the giant one to the one on the
desk sure so the King was right there I
can't do that you gotta push it push it
all the way down to the white one yeah
again if we're wrong there's poison gas
involved uh-huh one more there you go
so now technically that's check for
white but yeah you want to get
Oh evil I think this guy's evil actually
there's this um I can't believe I almost
killed your tuber her death like why are
chest commentary and he makes it really
accessible and it's really fun to watch
I've been kind of getting into it I
don't historically like chess yeah but
I've always wanted to we have that on
twitch with go there's like a thriving
go community now and it's really cool
how they'll be like explaining go while
you're watching it and go and chess are
very in tune they're not the same but
they you know but like you're right he's
full I forgot you could draw out that
blue herb on the ground for now as well
you think oh you know what this is gonna
be this gonna be the other black wing I
think I mean that we got the other wing
remember you got a wing from the book or
maybe it's a container for that chemical
sure that sounds promising
who's Marcus we finally did it the new
virus the probe genitor hmm want to
carry back and started detail
investigations Spencer says he's gonna
start a company but I just don't think
he's going to ever go through with it
hold on why is Marcus talking like this
just funnier if it's like they're in a
relationship and he's disappointed with
him yeah Spencer keeps asking me to be
the director of this training facility I
think it's cuz the business but he's
becoming an intolerable [ __ ] what pushy
he's I can turn this to my advantage I
need a special facility to properly
explore all the virus secrets
place well no one will get in the way
I have a love bomb by my ding-dong I
don't know what to do about this Spencer
he's complaining all the time he thinks
of the progenitor there's nothing more
of the money spinning tool I'm running
on a platform of pro genitals he's very
progressive he's bad for my research if
I'm gonna go for progenitor nation well
thanks at my own position hey we're
getting back toward the date of the
original Resident Evil Oh No wow that's
the dumbest thing I've ever said of
course we are this is the prequel too
risky but it's getting toward my
birthday
parts of resonable to take place on my
birthday are you looking at I'm not
looking in the Mike while I eat it
doesn't matter where you're looking when
you eat noise comes out of your mouth
not your eyes like a WB Yeats poem noise
comes out in through the eyes out
through the mouth I look at you and I
cry mixing hip to leech DNA was the
breakthrough I call this new virus t4
Tyrone he's no glue I can't hope for
real progress experimenting on mere
rodents only humans someone seems to
suspect something about my experiments
but if they catch me then they're gonna
get some virus those of low intelligence
they will never have the privilege of
tasting this sense of joy and
satisfaction oh he's going after spencey
um
someone came looking for the tea and the
leeches people are [ __ ] with his lab
stuff I know this was like eight pages
long
he loves his leeches and William and
Albert but Spencer are you still reading
this I don't think we need to be here
still yeah okay so we weren't going to
open up the boot book of evil it's gotta
be the wing what else gotta be what is
that that's a very specific shape to
hollow out a book for whatever Rebecca
was so dumb that she like didn't like
she thought that's how all books were
she's like okay she's trying to read it
and in bed just nonchalantly flipping
pages she's reading around those where's
the wing I don't think he's playing that
joke as well as it wasn't my head no I
just don't think it was a good joke
though cool the the way I explained my
sister humor
okay it's like a baseball player who
swings at every single pitch as hard as
you can
I strike out most the time and that
happens a lot sometimes I [ __ ] smash
a homerun that scaffolding reminded me
of spider-man I've been playing a lot of
spider-man oh you needed you to direct
me to the next door well we could
offload the wing okay let's go the match
is not this way it's this way
let me check them out it's not it was
the other way that's why we check them
in up
I feel like I'm not the Babe Ruth of
jokes I'm like a Bunter he's continually
shitty from said okay I wonder if he's
gonna trigger something bad I mean it's
a little come this far
feeling real frisky the scales of
justice please don't be a zombie Thank
You Bobby please don't be a zone give a
[ __ ] what's behind it as long as I get
his painting is in the ground it was
Marcus bike he synched it with some of
an audio but before that place forever
there's a red herb down there yeah that
does not seem like a place you want to
go yet I just don't feel good about that
at all do the other two night doors
first okay let's find out where they are
it's that one right there the front door
is one as well oh let's do that remember
in the first game when you went out the
door the dogs attacked you the first
time I'm gonna take one of these cuz I
just feel like they'll be beneficial
don't you think sure
like I have no [ __ ] bullets so Oh
actually it looked like on the map
there's a hook shot what yeah you can go
back and get it you're saying like look
open the map am I reading that correctly
it's a hook-shot platformer thing oh I
see the arrow who knows I don't know
let's look around maybe their stuff just
so much I don't know about hook shots
please don't be dogs it's an elevator
that makes way more sense okay it must
need a fuse is out power these there's
no [ __ ] birds out here goddamn birds
hate birds
oh my god you're doing this on purpose
it's hard to leave when it changes the
direction I feel like we keep
continually rediscovering why they had
tank controls in the first place there
anything on the ground there
[ __ ] why would it even let me out here
that's weird there's like no benefit to
this being here it's just like if I have
a battery I know I can use it that's so
weird
I've got some decent news I think we're
like halfway through this game what
that's so surprising ish well okay
that's not so like I think I've done a
boss yet besides yeah you did a
centipede okay and the crab okay it
might not be halfway in terms of why
they keep just enlarging crustaceans
that's actually oddly enough let me I
haven't got the chance to go through
comments yet someone said it was Ava Ava
Cassandra on YouTube said also that
lobster centipede thing fight was so
dumb why is every boss in this game just
take this real life creature now make it
big yeah that's a lot of these games
it's true okay so where's the final door
I thought there were three a miner was
was that one okay yeah oh
I mean it's yellow now you're right I
don't know where that is though it's the
stairs oh yeah that's the wet room
so that's not far you go check it out
also since we're probably going into the
basement soon you should go back and get
those grenades bring him back here and
load him with a grenade launcher a
grenade launcher
yeah it's oh wait that's the hook shot I
thought it was the hook shot but you had
a grenade launcher you fought the
centipede with it it wasn't great I
don't take it but yeah but you're saying
go get the grenades at some point before
you go into the basement but first off
there's grenades here should I load
those in you can in a minute when we
come back this is a hook shot okay cool
there's also red Arab University and a
green army of those chairs I forgot you
never took those after she can convene
these I don't even need to yeah what's
she on yellow she's doing orange I'm
gonna do it I wouldn't use combine why
not cuz the blue I mean you've got cuz I
can just eat the blue to stop poison
yeah but you're kind of like you're not
on I think you're wasting a full heal on
just using her well I wasn't gonna use
it sorry I was just gonna combine them
oh let me clarify I'm gonna combine them
and then not eat them okay
cool so do you remember how to get to
this doe me please yes go back go come
back to your floor it is go up one floor
yes that's what I thought yes that's
what I was going to say cheering think
so
it's like 10 zombies in here was that
that was like a flying thing we both
heard it we inch forward a little bit to
see what's up okay but yeah I go first
with Billy yep
on my way back the [ __ ] is that should I
tell her stay there's like some giant
fly some giant bee or some giant there's
a cord right there okay I'll check it
out it's because I accidentally told her
not to follow me
she don't still shoot though right I'm
honestly not sure hey we do me a favor
can I see the exploit real fast
I pushed the gameplay over too far
I think is it okay it's fine never mind
I just wanna double-check I'm gonna
change oh no that's fine I'm gonna
change to the shotgun what do you think
cuz there's three of them there's three
of them I don't think we should be up
here then what let's go let's go in the
basement find more items and stuff and
then come back up here if there's three
things and we shouldn't be up there but
I shot things miners kill it I think you
should run and go to the basement first
you're really low in stuff all right let
me turn off her solo so she doesn't die
I want to make I want to oh partner I
see that's Billy now yeah I want him to
be cooperating with me and I'm gonna be
heard I'm gonna run away that way he
takes the damage I thought about this
you [ __ ] idiot now you should just
just try it
no not yeah you might as well now what's
he doing he's following me exist um as a
but I forgot
that looks good
do that kill them I didn't mean to do
that
I got it they not get to me two more
there was poor one more which are you
gonna help me okay hold on a lot just
happened there are four of them a B you
didn't take any damage which is awesome
so I think in the long run that was good
and now you'd have to worry about them
later
did they Three Stooges syndrome where
they could all get through the door at
the same time I think you just cheesed
it kind of an accident like Dark Souls
Boston from a called duty zombies I'm
the greatest gamer in the whole world
well okay yeah this way this is the
final one isn't it yes what's that noise
me breathing it was terrifying sorry
come here beer okay she's the only one
with bullets how dangerous is this
situation swap some bowls to him I don't
think I can I have no idea what's
through this door again I'm doubting
whether we should have come up here yet
I mean I assume I can [ __ ] leave oh
we've been wrong about that before if
it's a centipede we're in trouble
Oh hot-diggity done
we we Thank You Manuel reload that [ __ ]
I forget how circle am in circle oh cool
you're in like an observation room of
medical variety god this game is so
funny oh satellite what's down there who
do you work for who are you
this looks like three items I need to
get that look like tombstone we have a
good overall mission now there's a
message carved into the control panel
the three fundamental principles of the
umbrella corporation oh I remember what
that was it was like follow lead heart
totally dignity faith love Jesus I had
Jesus for the first time last night in
like six years it was really so glad you
said the rest that sentence I couldn't
imagine someone who's never had a cheese
it before him the other day the other
day I was on Costco and I was trying to
find cheez-its to buy them and I
searched for the word cheese and it I
couldn't find them and I was like I
guess they don't sell cheez-its anymore
and it's because without the they don't
spell it with to you it's easy so my
girlfriend who was lovely got a bunch of
like groceries and you know how so we
were having a crazy week so we ordered
through the delivery service uh-huh
which cost like a dumb amount more like
20 bucks more so I don't recommend it
mm-hmm they couldn't find these uh
there's this company called
I don't even know him a lot of names but
there's a company called late July have
you ever had those chips really good
they I don't yeah it's not like there's
gonna be an endorsement on this I baked
a cake once on gamespot and I just
didn't hide any of the labels and I said
it's because I'm lazy like I'm not
endorsing this flour yeah
okay to the basement
but they couldn't find these like really
good like I think they're organic or
something I don't really give a [ __ ]
about that but they were like regardless
they couldn't find those so they like
message me through the app saying is
this a valid replacement and they asked
if like cheez-its I was like nope but
then I was like well actually I haven't
at cheese's in my years so yes and I had
them but they were they're still good
cheez-its you're good I like the
parmesan ones so I really still don't
have a lot of bullets are weak still
cool with this I think this is like a
whole new area you're going into like
I'm just saying like if there's zombies
in there he's got 15 bullets and a mall
table and she's got 14 aids really quick
just so we don't see later lets back
upstairs you should have said that
before I I just don't feel like I heard
you you have to speak up maybe I feel
like no one's going to listen to you
more no matter how often you say that I
feel like that was unnecessarily harsh
sometimes you gotta build a bit of a
wall buttercup I do have a wall Billy
you just left over mine with a with
siege Tower that's cool it's very cool
of me
follow me dummy it's in it looks like
she has to poop it's in this room it
does like I really think about it I'm so
so hot Mike that's weird
you have poop issues you poop in urinals
and you like girls who are about to poop
and you're weird it's not what I was
saying that is what you're saying I'm
just going for shock value wrong door no
you're right
no what's the wrong door no stop I
honestly forgot oh there's a blue herb
in the other room keep me lover eating
more a little bit sue thanks I like I
was far away I thought you know weird
from me
no that's so sweet Oh from where I
usually sit I feel like I am so far away
from you sometimes where are you did you
see that
today it's obviously hurricane florence
is bearing down on the East Coast
hopefully our if any of you are from
Carolinas I hope you're out safely but
that's terrible
we've had so many problems with just
extreme weathers recently and not just
fires out here the fires in California
are some of the saddest things I've ever
seen
they're so sad all the animals they're
so scared and they can't drink water
it's awful
she says yeah um there was that
earthquake in Japan oh yeah I was near
Osaka right I don't know I can't agree
or disagree I was very sad about that
there's a Nintendo Direct earlier today
and they announced excuse me a ton of
things like ports and new games new
Animal Crossing next year Isabel that's
the right word from Animal Crossing is
going to smash but also they are they
also announced
I don't need sounds like I would like
but I don't play it I don't necessarily
think you should take it it's just nice
to have the grenades here I was gonna
come convince them are you saying I
shouldn't be what was I talking about
indirect you want me to save or should I
just go you can probably save now you
think me save all the time I just don't
feel that confident about how many you
have a bunch three more up in that
Chester that's true
I also think I set a bad precedent in
the first season of Knievel ever by not
letting you save all that off well
there's times when you like I feel like
you actually can run out of pucks and if
that was the case I mean it would really
screw us
it's kind of hard both ways like I don't
like it
but anyway so Assassin's Creed Odyssey
apparently in Japan you're able to
stream it like you pay Mario game no you
pay per hour to stream the game through
like the Internet in Japan they it
reminds me I would have just avoid that
you [ __ ] idiot
well that went well I've done it again
you should probably switch the Billy a
and B that reminded me of resin evil
because resin evil seven I think was the
first game if not like the first big
game to do that
stream it didn't really work here
because I'm [ __ ] out of ammo
like I'm out 15 rounds but I am out of
ammo be an alarmist I'm on an alarmist
you're fine I don't appreciate anything
about you I'll [ __ ] she kept her goddamn
pucks she or the person controlling I
said what I said should I drop those or
just drop them right here you're gonna
come back this way to get upstairs let's
drop them right here all right
we're still in the item box mindset mean
to get out of it I feel like it's a
detriment to us for this game that we've
been playing all the other games leading
up to us you mean
they created betting relative to this
game they created bad habits not bad
habits but have it nonetheless all right
while you're doing this stuff
Oshin i believe i'm pronouncing that
correctly if it's anything like the
irish gaelic pronunciation
congratulations on the hundredth episode
about here since day one still loving
the show thing mr. shakedown has a tough
[ __ ] [ __ ] you get him you [ __ ] idiot
mr. shakedown five days ago head up
always keep your guns reloaded from the
inventory screen after encounters
they'll call it your pants down I'm
proud of you marry Valentine it's about
time you start making them executive
decisions that's from Harlow do carol
was new ski I'm with you from the first
episode great show for great games five
not five and six winky face happy 100th
from Jimmy we moanin apologies if I'm
butchering that Oh Mikey Mikey you might
be all cool and [ __ ] in urinals and all
but could have still want a costume I
know I'm cool Paulin please no now I'm
here since episode 1 reven house are two
things one dope ass jail cosplay by mary
and second that end music after last
week's episode destroyed my ears I
apologize for that I forget that when we
put the ending outro on gamespot videos
it has music to it oh so it's a really
loud we used a new
in the software we use we use the new
presentation outro deceased deceased
preserved way my way
savage no it's not just savage it's
csavage like Colin savage why is that
there and Midge d wait that's their last
name his name is first name is savage no
no look Matthews Kay Matthews Oh
deema JH what about Keith I agree and I
have a brother-in-law named Keith I'm
not gonna say his last names people
can't find it but his this is weird I
don't think people would find your I beg
to differ
people Terrance with two R's I have a
friend whose name is Terrance and it's
got one R and every time someone spells
it they spelt with two R's suck it up
Terrance alright you're making fun of my
brother-in-law so I view my
brother-in-law's my brother-in-law's
brother
you know what I'm a creepy basement you
know what's ironic is I just gotten rid
of those pucks in that hallway should I
just leave these here maybe and then
there's these plants but I could combine
don't do that until you know you need
you that's a long hallway oh you just
came through it never let's go for it
feeling feeling spry please no zombies I
have no bullets oh [ __ ] this looks bad
is this a is this a boss it looks like a
boss this looks like a boss cuz it's a
[ __ ] room
this looks like [ __ ] scary I don't
like it
well looks like there's about two I'm
glad I could be of service don't look go
inside
don't leave he's no Steve don't look at
my dukes
oh it's a torture room I can't believe
this
I heard iron maidens aren't real really
yeah I heard like I don't know if that's
accurate though I heard they were like
made up and created but not like a thing
you should google it
put it on Snopes Snopes rre iron maidens
real do it do it I will I'm excited now
I don't know what these wait huh what
are you even trying to get it to I don't
know
can't laughter now
can I see the keys there's another room
there's a piece of paper
due to the recent lightning strike the
power regulations continue to be
inoperative blah blah blah blah blah the
equipment is so rundown if you wish to
exit rapidly set the indicator to 70
check first though that everything is
connected to the chain alright how do I
know if everything's connected to the
chain does it tell me what do I know
they all look like they're connected
because they're all lobbies but I don't
I'm gonna do this Mary style
careful careful
I think I actually had it
I have no idea what I'm doing
um because these aren't number based are
they are they all gauges of 50 is that
what that is so this is like 25 oh I
might be like too dumb for this cuz like
this is if this is are they all 100 and
this is saying it's 65 like the first
panel but it's not going up to 55 so
it's not accurate you know you know go
up go down
go up again it makes me too much
goddammit
for the record I saw that it's kind of
like Keenan yeah it looks like the Greek
historian Polybius apparently they were
real but like weren't as widespread as
like I heard like a lot of them were
like decor but you didn't actually
[ __ ] kill so it didn't originate in
the Middle Ages like a lot of people
think it was long before that like we're
talking like 100 beats Eric yeah 100 BC
you are wasting your time
I have already claimed this place for
myself hair is so trespassing and I am
very territorial god I had like no seals
or attacks
he released a monkey did he release it
now I hope I don't [ __ ] have the
ability to fight this
I really don't all right what just
happened
entity of that crazy young man
impossible but if somehow it is true
then umbrella will be finished if the
old conspiracy against dr. Mongoose is
revealed mr. Spencer's career will be
over
not to mention ours too so the time has
come at last
what are you going to do I will simply
say goodbye to umbrella the biological
weapon utilizing the t-virus has almost
been completed our only remaining task
is to acquire combat data you can't be
serious I refuse to abandon my work I
have finished the research on the
t-virus but I need a little more time to
complete the more powerful G virus
that's the virus based on my brother
Gary he's so annoying my initial plan
and who are the stars members into the
mansion their superior combat training
should make them perfect test subjects
fine in the meantime
something must be done about that madman
as I recall you RC is equipped with a
self-destruct device in the basement
I'll find it set it off and annihilate
the place to nothing more than a massive
rubble
why did the ape stop attacking her apes
don't like going down holes oh my god is
this time because I don't have any
bullets figure it out
with what
so probably have to go upstairs
[Music]
so she's here yeah
so am i saving her how do I get to her
[Music]
I mean those doors are open this one no
no in the hallway I think you were
running by it because you were fighting
spiders oh please no spiders please no
spiders I have no bullets
I have no bullets I have no bullets I
have no bullets I have nothing I cannot
save oh my god yeah just keep going
you're fine
they're not gonna follow you guys oh yes
they are it's a monkey what does that
have to do with it open doors haven't
you ever seen Jurassic Park it's not a
monkey if they have thumbs
man the other dexterously it's here
right check it out actually Raptors
don't have thumbs but you know what I
mean they got fingers god bless what is
that I don't know but get the ammo
is she in trouble yeah but I don't know
if it's actually time to you is just
don't let the music sway you I feel like
the music is swaying me there that was
more stressful
all right search the rest is right hit
him
oh the shotgun shell pecker kill him and
get those or no he's knocked down get
the Shaka shell behind him I'll just
kill him
there must be something else
yep yep get him get him yeah nice
oh you can't carry him your fault
there's another one behind me that's why
he keeps pointing backwards like that
just go kick him in the face let him
grab me I I'm not ready he's dead
you're good I think you're still fine
now you need those tracker cells right
before I help her
yes really yes okay sorry [ __ ] what was
that
I'm freaking out I know
just calm down don't you tell ya drop
those are you sure no but do it oh yeah
you drop those yeah I don't know you
know the shock itself you're never sure
about anything
yeah but I've led you through seven
games now eight now what was that noise
was that a monkey I hope not
can you feel no I think I understand
where I am so she's in the hole
I'm coming coming babe it's amazingly
she couldn't like pick up but she could
like get a remote and like click on it
and be like get out go go don't fight
them don't fight them they're gonna kill
you
go I can't wait I have to go through
here this is where she is just go
through the door no go through the door
get out of here okay you're fine
so right first dates right first aid use
first aid yeah yeah use that and then go
through the door I'm telling you I'm
[ __ ] vagina
what that's where she is
I know but so what do you want
[Music]
yeah go back upstairs are you serious
she's gonna die
no she's not it's not me so negative you
stop being something good
I have already so many monkeys upstairs
so like take these yeah so like a
different way to fall
yeah
[Music]
as goddamn monkeys
they're gorillas they look like I don't
know anything about these okay to the
dining room wherever it is we came out
it's down a floor I think like here
[Music]
yeah the dining rooms I went to the
right I believe fear yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay go on
it's one of these doors from here but
also you should give molotovs in the
main room you can grab again yeah yeah
you should grab those I I really don't
think the timing is as important as you
think it is it's just I'm just worried
that I didn't kill that zombie cuz I
just shot in like seven times yeah bring
maltose
so annoying I like I've like I'm like so
short on ammo again been in worse
situations I don't feel like it my
girlfriend's getting attacked by like
three monkeys and I have no girlfriend
she's doing I don't think it's I think
it's this door right here yes the
kitchen
Oh is the kitchen isn't the ketone
through the other door I'm sorry
[Music]
so here yeah
looked already came here though I did
come here I've been here many times
[Music]
yeah okay so this is right think so
[Music]
oh that the steam is turned on yeah I
know what you get though it's my
girlfriend oh wait what I mean I don't
know what your employer is like right
now um you said no for now and check
your report click it'd be my last
I chose comeback take one just to have
it and then you could swap once you get
back with everybody all right I need to
save her okay yeah so basement okay cool
so what am i doing is this the monkeys
okay yes hold on so shocked because
we're toward the end of the episode you
haven't say well I am looking up some
help for this so apologies
yeah but don't try to kill them you're
gonna get to Rebecca first so just save
Rebecca and [ __ ] off no no there's a
door you're gonna go through then
that'll save Rebecca I'd to go through a
door yeah and also we're toward the in
the episode and saving and [ __ ] so I
don't know where the door is
I know you're gonna take a right after
you come in alright here we go
just dodged the [ __ ] monkey so much
to monkeys if in doubt shoot them yeah
but don't but don't ya stick along that
wall that's a [ __ ] lie you're good
you're good you're hon hon hon honey yes
stick along yes okay you see where
you're going
yeah [ __ ] bolt along that wall take a
right in there right
correct if I keep going you nice no not
that door
well you maybe it was oh no this is the
typewriter I think you're safe
regardless ha I don't think I'm open the
map up you're fine like you still dodge
them you're good so this isn't it no but
you're still so as soon as you come
through we'll go yeah hope it's not a
lot of monkeys there
I think they spawn farther away from
[Music]
those things suck like what they
literally are just taking animals I mean
I don't know why I haven't God that was
stressful
the monkeys she sparked did you hear
that thank you no mentioning she's just
keeping my word you promised a koala
each other could you have just member
that first room you wanted to with the
monkeys cuz you just have dodged them
and then that was the room you're in
yeah this make us I mean you're envious
easier dodge Miss Ono cuz you went past
all those herbs again thanks Rebecca
my first mission and I've already
disobeyed orders so much for my great
launch Horseman
don't look at her look I probably won't
live long enough to worry about the low
res Norman Reedus yeah why doesn't she
like message on there like I just need
to know screw Billy Laney there's
monkeys in here
did you kill 23 people I'm not going to
judge you I mean a little bit want to
know the truth I'm high as [ __ ] right
now it was around this time last year oh
my god is this really the time to be
reminiscing yes it is our unit was
ordered to Africa to intervene in a
civil war
our mission mr. ray a hideout of some
guerrilla forces located deep surreal a
jungle but no hideout was far away from
our entry point died from the heat
others were killed by the enemy in the
end only four of us survived
only there was no guerrilla hideout what
do you mean I've never even been to
mountains in charge had its operating
based on Ryan finish we couldn't just go
back home empty-handed oh no our leader
ordered us to attack an innocent village
kill them oh please sir cease fire
immediately shut up do it
yikes so did you execute those innocent
people forget about it doesn't matter
anymore that was then this is now
besides you said you wouldn't judge me
yeah he's got a point not judging you
but it does matter
look now my people think you killed
those MPs in the van but I don't think
you did those gonna be dogs right when
they attack the van
you were able to escape isn't that right
you don't get it
I've only got two choices left by the
report to the Marines and serve out my
sentence or keep on running for as long
as I can that's all oh good
typewriter sweet and ribbons oh oh right
info can you open your map I'm really
curious if we'd oh no you did have to go
that way okay we did not go out of our
way for no reason because that door is
locked the bottom door okay okay that's
good to know
I don't regret as much okay cool yeah
I'd say safe that was a pretty stressful
episode it was a stressful listen um
wait hold on does that sign say no
loitering down here come on there we go
but it's good that is funny well they
don't want you loitering it's funny cuz
you were on the ledge oops
good David pick advance
hey you Congrats on the first hundred
episodes Javier Herrera by the way
awesome anniversary video Mary but I say
if possible we want to see the mythical
Mary 10-minute cut of 100 scares
Resident Evil sounds epic and a lot of
fun like Ricardo you saved anyway why
you you and your spoilers like Ricardo
Jose said in the comments we've watched
100 plus hours of Knievel goodness 10
minutes of it is a walk in the park
editing a 10 minute video takes yeah ok
I was going to it was just 15 minutes
long like I just didn't think anyone
what am i watching the entire thing I'm
not turning on this ship free the kamini
Mary we appreciate your effort freaking
8087 says I want to see ten minutes of
resident
if you purpose if you proof in a urinal
quickly did you wipe yeah I did
graduation 100th episode and watch all
the previous 99 you guys did a great job
that's odd
in Andreas I'm just kidding spoilers now
okay
cool spoil ease all right next time on
Kamini we go after those monkeys and
then realize yeah as always thanks every
for joining us is up every Saturday I
have a good rest of the weekend we will
like I said I'm time traveling a little
bit hopefully by the time hopefully by
the time you watch this ayat we will
have gotten up the three-minute scare
version video that Mary did again Thank
You Ava Cassandra for the awesome work
Ava for the fan art we love it and it's
not fan are excited it thank you
personally from us Friends of it for the
dope art all right no it is yes it's yes
but as always have a good rest of the
weekend and we'll see you next week when
we're probably gonna have to fight a
bunch of evil guerrillas
I just killed them they're dead